I thought there was no hell we're in
hell
we're in the matrix this is how we are
whoa oh [ __ ]
Wow get that whoa yeah oh my brother's
about to do some it's like even like the
word cool yeah yeah here we go diagram
oh that's that's course that's the
upside down from no division division
yeah yeah mathematics right yeah yes but
you know what this really means what
this is the Sun above us yeah and this
is the black hole Sun like Soundgarden
stranger things upside down yeah yeah
this is this is this is real [ __ ] this
is what tell us what the Sun is and the
black the Sun is the what you see above
you yeah but the black hole Sun is you
know we can't see ya but we're always
believed like even in Christianity that
don't go down here this is hell but it's
this that's really everything we've
talked is reversed it's real this is
really um the land of Perpetual Twilight
we need to go down there to the black
hole like you ever know it's like when
you ever you pray you're really
directing your attention to the black
hole son yeah you know I'm saying yeah
yeah yours is a division a queer divided
and that's a way out of this matrix
because to be free of grounded or
recycled here in this world where all
you have all been recycled know so much
about it what do you feel in Gilbert
doing the Pringles you could have said
something at their Walmart or we get the
Pringles thing no I'm just starting to
realize stuff now because I thought you
that what did you read this but isn't it
cool I just look stuff up man it's all
okay it's the stuff that I've been like
the reptilian stuff eventually what's
that stuff Gilbert's not familiar with
your opportunity and belief yeah
oh you know just about reptilians they
live off human energy like negative
yeah there you can't seem there outside
of our spectrum yeah yeah in the fourth
dimension yeah and they're they're like
parasites they live off of our or energy
yeah they use words it's like puppet but
this stuff's interesting because I'm
like because it all talks about symbols
in like the way we're like controlled by
symbols like everything like through the
media the all-seeing eye and how is
there a youtube video I can watch
yeah quasi quasi luminous you know so
much about this yeah I mean there's
another name Devin Maggie look Devin
Matt so yeah if we look up quasi
luminous yeah right
he breaks it down dude he does dunno
some cheesy what color is he he's a
white dude and who's he I don't know
he's just he makes YouTube videos and
you'll learn a lot though yeah I'll tell
no our sound guy on tour like I think I
scared him though so shout-out to Chris
yeah we're talking one night in the
hotel room and I was like weird like
talking about conspiracy theories and
yeah yeah and this and then but then
when I saw that I'm like whoa symbols
like there's like deeper meanings and
are these symbols like the CBS symbol
that means something old video games
remember all I know I have Horus you
know that stuff yeah Egyptian symbol
here this Red Bull as did two bulls that
you know ironically enough that is that
does that is duality and stuff the Sun
something I don't know about the Fiji
bottle but see the pedal represent the
wings wings angel wing they're all dying
the Red Bull one definitely know what
about says these grasshoppers yeah
grandma is she's a demon look at her
she's a lizard demon but this makes
sense cuz it's a symbol that we've known
as division but there's a deeper meaning
it's like we are divided within between
worlds would you put that picture up of
the division symbol like he didn't know
what it was I don't think he knows how
to divide i know how to divide I don't
know how to do long long later um Wow
you know what's so weird about you is
that you
remember remember that book that I got I
was at the post office yes and then and
then and then it scared up he threatened
to get me locked up in an insane asylum
my neighborhood ni'mal hey dude I'm on
Wilcox so I'm at the post office cuz I
ordered a book online oh my god the
other dimensions the glimpses of other
realities yeah i think barbara larson or
or something and then we start opening
it I opened it and then there was like
crazy pictures of like aliens yeah yeah
you're like you disappeared for eight
hours at night and that 500 more you
came out home a lian's look at the ghost
I was so hard notable people that are
alive right now who you for sure think
are reptilians like which is there
anybody in like politics is Donald Trump
a reptilian the Queen and England
[ __ ] the Pope yeah all the Pope's
that have ever anyone in politics maybe
they're they're not reptilian but
they're definitely [ __ ] you know cross
brain position yeah yeah yeah so one let
me ask you know so Bill Clinton looks in
the mirror and he's aware that he's
happy and lizard I don't know I can't
answer that I don't know I don't know so
you don't really believe it I mean I
can't name off the top well I don't know
exactly whose crossbred with reptilians
you know meeting with you know it's
interesting I mean people believe in
like look people die for the name of
Allah in the name of religion it's like
I can't I can't have like study other
things outside of like that that
religion shoots like a [ __ ] to
control you it's a belief system dude
just saying I wanted to like like
looking up all alternate thinking that's
great you know but yet quasi luminous
and a Devin Maggie Lamont second one uh
Devon Maggie
Devin Maggie ma dgy devil yeah he's a
seasoned [ __ ] smart kid
this kid knows what's up yeah the kid
yeah no he's in his 20s you know yeah
it's not a kid but you know mid 20s yeah
I don't know just look him up man how
does anyone know about anything I mean
[Music]